it's been one year since restless
individual traders shaken by the
coronavirus pandemic started what they
thought would be a revolution against
wall street most people remember it is
the story of small investors banding
together to beat the street and make
huge profits but that's not exactly what
happened the truth is the meme stock
craze and the band of angry reddit
traders brought the hedge funds big
banks and professional money managers
a big payday but the story doesn't end
there the battle for the soul of the
stock market and the future of investing
that's still going on i'm going to
explain how the so-called revolution
really lined wall street's pockets how
the market has changed since january
2021
and what the new world of investing
means for the stock market going forward
we're going to dig into all that but
first let me remind you of how we got
here
build as the finance world's david
versus goliath most people first started
hearing about meme stocks in january
2021 as gamestop stock started taking
off the army of traders who had gathered
on the wall street bets subreddit had
discovered something of a cheat code
they identified and bought stocks with
high levels of short interest that hedge
funds were lining up to bet would fail
gamestop was one of the main stocks the
subreddit had identified at the time it
had been rising steadily through 2020 as
the overall market recovered but during
the month of january 2021 the stocks
price rose by 1600 percent for the hedge
funds there were some big losses melvin
capital a hedge fund with 12.5 billion
dollars in assets last january lost more
than half of its clients money short
selling gamestop the company had huge
uncovered bets the gamestop stock would
fall in price then on january 28th robin
hood and many of the most popular retail
trading brokerages announced they would
halt buying in gamestop and several
other stocks that retail had been buying
that seemed to change everything furious
retail traders blamed robin hood and a
cabal of hedge funds politicians and
money managers for conspiring to stick
it to the little guy this is the part of
the story where most people stop paying
attention but it's where the real story
of the retail trading revolution begins
they thought that they'd found a great
money making scheme and a way to blow
multi-billion dollar holes in some of
the biggest funds on wall street my
colleague spencer jacob who edits wsj's
heard on the street column wrote a book
called the revolution that wasn't that
just isn't what happened they mostly did
not make money and they poured a lot of
money into wall street's pocket the
retail trading bonanza led to record
profits for firms like goldman sachs and
morgan stanley even robin hood raked in
massive gains how did this happen
traders were buying options and buying
and selling stocks multiple times a day
every trade that's made is routed
through a market maker that pays
brokerage firms a fee this is how
companies like robinhood that don't
charge users a direct fee for trading
make their money companies like citadel
securities are the market makers they
take a fraction of the cost of the trade
and they pocket that it's a tiny
percentage of ascent but when there are
millions of trades happening every hour
that adds up to a lot of money at the
end of the day more trades also means
more money flowing through investment
banks like goldman jp morgan and
deutsche bank and while melvin capital
and a few others suffered most hedge
funds did very very well many retail
traders did pretty well too but
eventually the whole thing fell apart
between january 28th and
a week later
gamestop lost almost 90 percent of its
value but the story isn't over many
retail traders were first drawn to
trading by the craze and meme stocks
now they're driving a few big changes to
the way the stock market operates
perhaps the biggest we've seen is the
growth in options trading which reached
record levels in 2021 thanks to a huge
increase in activity from retail
analysts say this has been a big driver
of stock prices retail used to just be
along for the ride while big
institutions and hedge funds drove the
market that's changing we've almost
seemed like a confident shift kali cox
market analyst at etoro has been keeping
a close eye on what's happening retail
investors kind of know their power they
know their voice they know that they
they're able to move markets and
community they know how these markets
work
they know that you know the fed is
really engaged right now
and they've seen a market that you know
basically rewards those who kind of stay
in it the surge in trading by everyday
investors and the meme stock revolution
have even gotten lawmakers and
regulators to look into issues that some
retail traders have been screaming about
for years all this attention was the
result of these headlines but also the
fact that retail traders are becoming
too large to ignore jp morgan estimates
that individual traders have accounted
for over a third of stock market trading
several times over the past 18 months
they made up 40 percent of the trading
on peak days and retail bought seven
times more stocks in 2021 than they did
in 2019 young people are getting more
involved in the markets and that trend
doesn't look like it's going to stop
six in 10 people between the ages of 25
and 34 so they put more money in
investments over the last year this has
made wall street's professional class a
little nervous about getting burned
again according to a recent survey 85 of
hedge funds and 42 percent of
professional asset managers are now
tracking retail trading message boards
so while the big banks corporations and
wealthy financiers may have won the
first round it's clear that the reddit
revolution has made its mark the big
question is what's next retail traders
are showing no signs of taking their
ball and going home so far these traders
seem interested in risky bets like
options high-flying stocks and crypto
currencies but data also show that
retail traders are buying old-fashioned
index funds and blue chip companies like
apple and microsoft that shows that
retail traders are taking more risk but
they're also becoming more practical
investors who are thinking about
investing for the long term one big
difference has been a lack of fear
before the great financial crisis retail
was kind of seen as the money the dumb
money the money that would sell quickly
once something went wrong today's retail
trader is seen that when prices fall
it's not a time to be fearful and hide
it's time to buy the dip retail's top 8
buying days have all come when the s p
500 was down by at least 1.3 percent
traditional wall street has been
redefined in recent years by high
frequency trading algorithms and
artificial intelligence it's now being
upended by individual traders who have
some new ideas about how to buy and sell
it remains to be seen how this new force
will respond when stock prices fall and
stay down
and what that will mean for the market
and the economy
if you enjoyed this video hit the like
button and if you're interested in
markets and want to watch and learn more
subscribe to this channel to keep up
with my latest in the words of brooklyn
legend fabulous respect ain't earn twice
once you lose it it's gone and it's lame
when your money's right but you're using
it wrong that's it for now i'll see you
next time
[Music]